si vous ne la connaissez pas c'est que
catherine tate a passé sa vie derrière
les caméras nous brisons une fois de
plus le plafond de verre un honneur sur
lequel la première femme pdg de
radio-canada ne s'attarde pas déjà elle
se préoccupe des défi qui l'attend je
travaille comme fuck comme femme mais
c'étaient surtout leur rôle qui est
important catherine tate est nommé au
moment où l'industrie vit de profondes
perturbations avec la place grandissante
du numérique non seulement radio canada
doit adapter son offre aux nouvelles
plateformes
mais la société doit aussi rivaliser
avec les géants comme netflix ceux qui
ont travaillé à ses côtés depuis son
passage à téléfilm dans les années 80
voient en elle une précurseur c'est
quelqu'un qui peut voir l'avenir et qui
qui comprend que ce qu'il faut faire
d'être prêt elle est une des premières
qui produit des productions numériques
elles ont gagné de nombreux prix pour le
domaine numérique et elle voyait
vraiment les nouvelles voyait vraiment
cette transformation et le potentiel de
sa transformation là un bouillonnement
dans le monde médiatique que catherine
tate trouve stimulant
je crois que dans cette vague numérique
le rôle du radiodiffuseur public syfy si
radio canada n'aura jamais été aussi
importants que pour pour notre culture
notre dualité linguistique et notre
démocratie
mais face aux changements il faut plus
que jamais selon elle tendre la main aux
autres joueurs de l'industrie canadienne
les radiodiffuseurs privés des
organismes de presse les réseaux tels qu
et qui tiennent sans oublier les
radiodiffuseurs provinciaux
les représentants de l'industrie
l'industrie de la musique
et selon sept consultants catherine tate
qui a oeuvré temps au privé qu'au public
saura bâtir dépens je connais très peu
de personnes qui sont aussi connaissance
de l'industrie 2
la télévision l'audiovisuel le numéro en
plus des défis du numérique et de la
nécessité des partenariats catherine
tête insistent sur l'importance des
nouvelles régionales
mais avant de présenter sa vision
précise de l'avenir de radio canada cie
vie si elle veut d'abord consulter son
équipe
elle a devant elle trois mois avant
d'entrer officiellement en fonctions ici
madeleine le marais radio canada ottawa